[Música]
Bienvenidos a una semana en el mundo el
espacio de France 24 donde los
periodistas son los invitados y
analizamos las noticias que han marcado
la actualidad de la semana en esta
ocasión vamos a hablar de la violencia
policial en Francia a raíz del caso de
nael El adolescente al que mató un
policía en nanter el martes un caso que
ha hecho estallar la rabia Popular
acumulada en Francia también vamos a
comentar los secos que deja la rebelión
del grupo Wagner en Rusia contra la
cúpula militar rusa concretamente una
semana después de los hechos hay todavía
más preguntas que respuestas también
comentaremos la inhabilitación del
expresidente bolsonaro en Brasil y
finalmente el inicio del Tour de Francia
y antes de empezar el debate como
siempre vamos a saludar a nuestros
invitados hoy nos acompaña desde Buenos
Aires Juan elman periodista
especializado en política internacional
él trabaja trabaja en futuro en cenital
y en la televisión pública Argentina
Juan Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros
placer estar acá también nos acompañan
aquí en el estudio de Franz 24 nuestro
compañero Rodrigo sedano bienvenido
Muchas gracias rosa por la invitación
nuestra compañera también de France 24
le aurel bienvenida Gracias Rosa y desde
París desde el foco de la noticia
internacional nos acompaña nuestro
corresponsal Luis Miguel Cabrera Luis
Miguel Muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos con los reportes más
inmediatos de lo que sucede en la
capital francesa
un gusto Rosa estar con todo nuestro
colectivo pues sin más dilación Vamos a
entrar al grano al tema que marca la
actualidad de la semana y nos
trasladamos directamente a lo que sucede
en París donde los disturbios se suceden
noche tras noche como decíamos desde el
pasado martes el día en que un policía
mató a un adolescente llamado nael de 17
años
enter desde entonces las noches de
disturbios han estallado no solo en la
periferia de París de la capital sino en
varios puntos del país hay centenares ha
detenidos y decenas de miles de agentes
de la policía desplegados en todo el
territorio francés recordemos el vídeo
gracias al cual se conoció el siguiente
caso
viene lo veían en las imágenes lo hemos
subtitulado lo que se percibe de estas
palabras que sin duda van a ser claras
para esclarecer en la justicia lo
sucedido en las palabras se oye en la
cabeza dispara y al cabo de unos
instantes efectivamente un disparo con
arma de fuego que acabó resultando letal
para este adolescente llamado nahel bien
conectamos a directamente sin más
atilación con Luis Miguel Cabrera en
París Luis Miguel usted se encuentra de
hecho a 50 metros de donde ocurrió esta
muerte no
Así es es un punto pudiéramos decir
estratégico estamos en la Explanada que
une el distrito financiero de París la
defensa es el segundo Distrito
financiero más importante de Europa con
la prefectura de nantea a mi izquierda
están esas ciudadelas de que son barrios
realmente muy populares donde de donde
es este joven que fue asesinado por la
policía y frente a mí a 50 metros está
precisamente el lugar donde inició toda
esta tragedia y Luis Miguel usted ha
estado cubriendo estas protestas durante
estas noches consecutivas Cuál es el
llamado la reivindicación el sentimiento
de los jóvenes que están lanzando sus
rabia su ira contra el estado francés
yo empezaría apuntando Rosa el hecho de
que es difícil conversar con los jóvenes
con los más jóvenes con Los Adolescentes
porque su espíritu su intención está
completamente dominada por la ira por la
cólera y
ciertamente hemos conversado con con
varios de ellos con un gran número
pudiéramos decir de ellos quizás
probablemente varias decenas pero es
difícil sostener una conversación por
podría decirte más de un minuto Porque
lo que prima en este momento es la
pasión el sentimiento esa frustración
esa
impotencia que sienten los jóvenes por
lo que ha sucedido por uno de un miembro
de un compañero suyo alguien un vecino o
las madres por ejemplo que se se
muestran muy emocionadas también pudiera
haber sido su hijo
el que sufrió este este ataque o este
este incidente por parte de la policía
pero lo que prima es principalmente es
eso
sentimiento que nosotros hemos podido
apreciar Con lo poco que hemos
conversado con los jóvenes lo confirman
sus padres desde el primer día nos
decían estamos alarmados varios de ellos
estamos alarmados no podemos
controlarlos mi hijo no me escucha no sé
cómo explicarle que es necesario detener
la violencia que no siga a sus a las
personas que conoce que cometen actos
violentos de manera que ese es el
sentimiento sobre todo de los jóvenes y
con los adultos que hemos conversado
tenemos esta impresión que te acabo de
explicar también conversamos con un
padre que nos decía que su hijo se
siente acosado que tiene miedo cuando lo
para la policía que eso sucede con
frecuencia que él supone que está
relacionado con elementos de
discriminación racial y que cada vez que
tiene un control siente ganas o su
instinto le indica hacer Quizás lo mismo
que hizo nael y del otro lado también
por supuesto personas que están muy
incómodas muy molestas y que teman
incluso por su seguridad por todos estos
episodios de violencia pues Luis Miguel
precisamente me gustaría profundizar en
esta en los motivos a no de esta cólera
de esta rabia Más allá del hecho de que
estallara a raíz de del hecho de que un
policía matara a este Adolescente y
precisamente antes de que ocurrieran
estos hechos un mes antes estamos
hablando del 24 de mayo de este mismo
2023 cuando un grupo de alcaldes publicó
una Tribuna en el periódico Lemon del
principal periódico de Francia titulada
los suburbios están al borde de la
asfixia precisamente escuchemos un
párrafo muy breve de este artículo
una treintena de cargos electos locales
de diferentes procedencias políticas
piden en una editorial en el lemont un
plan de emergencia para los suburbios
para luchar contra la inseguridad
alimentaria congelar los precios de la
energía y financiar la renovación urbana
esta violencia estructural estas
carencias estas desigualdades que se
perpetúan en las periferias de Francia
también han sido recogidas como motivo
del estallido de esta de esta rabia en
un texto publicado por la redacción del
periódico media Park esto el 29 de junio
este jueves con un texto titulado la
muerte de nael es la chispa los motivos
de la rabia veamos
frente a los disturbios que sacuden a
Francia los representantes electos
locales los líderes de asociaciones y
los activistas de los barrios obreros
comparten la misma observación en todo
el territorio los servicios públicos
fallan para cada vez más habitantes la
policía es percibida con demasiada
frecuencia como hostil y racista y
faltan soluciones
lea te quiero trasladar a ti como bueno
como francesa como persona que ha
crecido y ha vivido gran parte de su
vida en Francia precisamente que nos
expliques cómo es la vida el día a día
en estos suburbios en la periferia bueno
rosa en la vida en estos suburbios
sí es una vida como marcada también por
mucha delincuencia pero por el contexto
de muy preciso de este espacio
geográfico yo hablo de la periferia de
París pero también pasa en otras grandes
ciudades de Francia también Bueno yo
quiero mencionar a Marsella donde hay un
contexto también muy difícil de vida y
el que el caso de París Está marcado por
mucha migración pero también por mucho
abandono del Estado yo creo mucha
juventud que no que no sabe qué hacer y
y justamente precisamente por eso lo a
mí me gustó mucho la expresión de La
chispa justamente que utilizo el
periódico media parte hablando de este
caso que no es un fuego que tomó tiempo
para para prepararse y hacerse o sea lo
de nael como muchos otros casos que ya
pasaron Solamente necesitamos un gesto
así corto rápido y un fuego iba a
estallar Entonces eso demuestra mucho
que son es una violencia que lleva años
años y años instalándose exactamente lea
precisamente recojo Esto del hecho de
que lleve años años y años instalándose
y repitiéndose de hecho a raíz del caso
de nael volvieron a preguntar a Mateo
cazovich él es el director de esta
película de culto en Francia el odio
laen en francés que recoge precisamente
como se va instalando esta rabia en los
suburbios sobre todo de las grandes
ciudades de ciudades hasta que está ya
de hecho hemos querido recordar el
inicio de esta película que empieza con
una frase que resume muy bien Este esta
situación
primero
[Música]
traducimos a brevemente este inicio que
dice Esta es la historia de un hombre
que cae de un edificio de 50 plantas
durante la caída para tranquilizarse no
para de repetirse De momento todo va
bien De momento todo va bien De momento
todo va bien pero lo importante no es la
caída sino el aterrizaje y es
precisamente el aterrizaje este
estallido de rabia no Y como dijo el
mismo director cada vez que hay un
suceso así el odio vuelve a las calles
lea precisamente Cuáles son los
episodios parecidos que han quedado
marcados en la memoria colectiva de
Francia bueno Yo hoy voy a recordar como
un par de casos y sobre todo un par de
nombres porque en esos casos los nombres
y las caras de esas personas son Se
volvieron símbolos dentro de las
organizaciones
anti racismo y dentro de también las
ongs que luchan para los Derechos
Humanos primero el caso más famoso
es el caso de dos adolescentes de de los
suburbios de París de crisis
en su huyendo de un control de policía
en 2005 en octubre del 2005 y después de
este caso y de esta muerte Trágica de
estas de estos dos adolescentes lo que
pasó es que los suburbios de París y
luego de unas otras ciudades de Francia
estallaron durante tres semanas y el
impacto la violencia era la rabia era
tan presente que el mismo presidente de
la época tuvo que llamar al estado de
emergencia en todo el país y esas se
quedaron como las protestas más fuertes
que marcaron Francia y por eso
justamente lo que está pasando hoy en
día Bueno siempre tenemos el espejo un
poquito de esas protestas de 2005 y
siempre eso va a ser la comparación
después en 2005 podemos mencionar
que también es un nombre que se
convirtió como un símbolo que murió en
2016 por asfixia y también un paro
cardíaco después de de de de su
detención por la policía y eso fue
cuatro años antes de de de de de de de
de Y entonces también este juego de
nuevo de espejos entre Estados Unidos y
Francia y el combate de la lucha de su
hermana Hasta traoré que también está
presente esos últimos días al lado de la
madre de nael de Este joven desde de 16
años que murió
que hizo un gran trabajo de
documentación y también de mediatización
alrededor del caso de su hermano y que
también Pues sí tuvo un papel muy
importante en esta lucha anti racista y
que todavía se ve hoy en día porque su
colectivo su organización está al lado
de esas familias que están seres
queridos pero al lado de las muertes
también podemos recordar que hay un par
de casos también de violencia que no
llegaron hasta la muerte pero también de
violencia documentadas muy importantes
que choquearon bastante la población
francesa entre muchos casos hay el caso
de Teo de 22 años en 2017 que durante
una interpelación
sufrió de una lesión anal de 10
centímetros por una Porra de la policía
y también el caso de Michelle un
productor musical con un vídeo de
policías que le dieron una paliza un
vídeo se circuló mucho en las redes
sociales y precisamente lea tu menú
mencionabas hace un rato la paradoja no
que Francia que a veces es reconocido
como el país de los Derechos Humanos
está señalado por muchas instancias
internacionales Naciones Unidas sin ir
más lejos por el racismo de la actuación
de la fuerza pública Juan le preguntó
desde Buenos Aires desde Argentina Cómo
ven este caso
a ver a mí me interesó un poco lo que
decía Miguel acerca de la palabra
ya el diccionario de García Márquez no
digamos muy latinoamericana a ver un
poco por esto que comentaban recién no
el caso de la violencia en las
periferias violencia que no solamente
policial no es una violencia ustedes lo
mencionaban con este editorial no que
tiene que ver también con el acceso a
derechos sociales económicos que bueno
una gran disparidad no lo que tienen los
grandes ciudades en los barrios
principales y lo que se ve en las
periferias ese tipo de violencia que
como bien escribían aparece no como con
esta chispa ante un caso con esta
visibilidad no muy ayudada por por la
difusión en redes sociales no estos lo
estamos viendo mucho en los últimos años
no Digamos como un hecho policial que
antes quizás pasaba desapercibido ahora
con redes sociales y con la posibilidad
de difundir material audiovisual digamos
genera mucha mucha repercusión lo
segundo que pensaba es un poco algo
vinculado al contexto No sé no Y esto
Más allá de esta protesta estamos viendo
ya hace varios meses hace varios años
digamos pero pero creo que en este
segundo mandato de macron
una situación de de una justamente una
cólera una ira que ya va más allá de la
situación puntual que escribía recién en
las periferias policial económica social
sino con no sé cómo describirlo pero
parece haber una desconexión muy grande
entre una porción de la sociedad porción
que habitan estas periferias pero
también en el mundo fuera de las grandes
ciudades no pienso en lo que fueron los
chalecos amarillos y la intensidad de
ese reclamo pienso También en los
indicadores que tenemos a nivel
electoral no solamente el voto por
fuerzas de corte más radical como el
caso de Marín lepén del lado sobre todo
por el nivel de abstención o sea
cantidad de gente que no vota entonces
uno ve el nivel de violencia que aparece
ante cada uno de estos reclamos que en
este caso será la violencia policial
pero hace unos meses recuerdan fue la
reforma jubilatoria y uno es muy difícil
pensar que algo O sea que que algo no va
mal no en términos bien profundos
estructurales no hay una desconexión muy
grande que en cada una de estas
protestas se marca con un nivel de
violencia también exacto y precisamente
Luis Miguel te quiero preguntar desde
Francia se espera una respuesta de las
autoridades que vaya más allá de la pura
represión policial de las protestas
Yo pienso que a corto plazo va a haber
lo que acabas de mencionar tú el
gobierno va a tratar de limitar el
accionar violento de estas de estas
personas Pero quizás en el más largo
plazo es precisamente hoy la primera
ministra Elizabeth donde tenía
planificadas varias actividades en Los
suburbios cercanos a París los suburbios
colindantes con la capital francesa
analizando precisamente esta situación
Eso sí el plan de Manuel macron con
respecto a los suburbios de París como
lo mencionaba ese artículo que leías al
inicio es digamos más realista en sus
palabras es más realista que los planes
de gobiernos anteriores pero según los
críticos del presidente Manuel macron es
por supuesto mucho menos ambicioso es
decir que pretende lograr un cambio de
forma menos radical y en un quizás plazo
de tiempo que va a demorar bastante O
sea no va a haber solución inmediata
para todos esas problemáticas que
describía muy bien lea y a la cual a mí
me gustaría personalmente agregar la
discriminación racial y el racismo y el
desempleo todo eso mezclado que existe
también en esas ciudadelas populares
Exacto Luis Miguel pues muchísimas
gracias por habernos acompañado desde
París desde donde está puesta la
atención internacional en estos momentos
Seguiremos muy atentos a cómo
evolucionan estas noches de protestas
Rodrigo y antes de cerrar este tema muy
rápidamente crees que es una situación
particular de Francia o que se puede
extrapolar a otros lugares del mundo un
poco esta esta rabia de ciertas clases
sectores de la población bueno Rosa creo
que la pregunta es sencilla La respuesta
es sencilla y tú lo puedes saber bien
también como por ejemplo en el
extrarradio de Barcelona quizás la
situación no es tan grave como lo que
estamos viendo en París pero también hay
un problema de integración Hay un
problema de atención a los barrios más
populares que muchas veces también está
lleno de juventud que son franceses
españoles belgas por en el caso de
Bruselas también que se sienten alejados
no se sienten acogidos por los países
que realmente les han visto nacer que
les han visto crecer y Sienten que les
están dejando de lado como quizás
también lo han visto que les dejaron de
lado de sus padres por eso a mí me
parece muy interesante poner la atención
en esto que ha dicho macron a los padres
a que intenten que sus hijos se queden
en casa pero yo comprendo que puede
haber padres también que digan no los
podemos dejar en casa y a lo mejor hay
algunos que tampoco quieren porque
sienten también esa rabia de los estados
Bueno pues se nos acaba el tiempo
Lamentablemente para continuar
analizando esta cuestión Muchísimas
gracias por habernos compartido tu
conocimiento y tu análisis sobre los
motivos de estas protestas Gracias y Les
propongo que pasemos a otra cuestión que
ha marcado sin duda la actualidad de la
semana desde hace exactamente una semana
no recordemos que el pasado viernes el
líder del grupo de mercenarios Wagner
empezó una rebelión contra la cúpula
militar rusa desde entonces ha habido
más preguntas abiertas A qué respuestas
dado que esta rebelión duró menos de 24
horas acabó con un pacto entre Vladimir
Putin y
mediado por el presidente de belarus
Alex un pacto sobre el que pesa una
enorme incógnita y un gran interés por
conocer los detalles exactos de momento
lo que está claro es que Vladimir Putin
ha desterrado a prigolgien a belarus y
que ha mantenido en su círculo a las
personas a los hombres contra los que se
dirigía este motín concretamente
hablamos del ministro de defensa y del
jefe del Estado Mayor Valery bien ahora
les pregunto Juan y Rodrigo Juan
empecemos por usted desde Buenos Aires
después de esta semana de esta tensa
calma de los últimos días en Rusia usted
se ha respondido a alguna de estas
preguntas abiertas cuáles son sus
conclusiones
pero ante todo diría esto siga habiendo
más preguntas que respuestas no lo decía
en el momento del programa yo la sigo
teniendo o sea hoy sigo teniendo más más
preguntas a ver ante todo Me parece que
hay que hay que preguntarse justamente
digo más allá de la semana las semanas
previas al movimiento de pregocen porque
ahora aparece lo ha hecho Estados Unidos
lo ha hecho New York Times esto de que
supuestamente había generales que sabían
de que privazin estaba intentando una
maniobra o estaba planificando una
maniobra se decía que Estados Unidos
también lo sabía eso también me parece
que está por verse pero concretamente en
esas veinticuatro horas digo hay dos
teorías que que circularon bastante que
no son excluyentes y que creo que está
bueno quizás compartir y yo de vuelta lo
pongo siempre entre signos de pregunta
pero es primero si efectivamente priego
sin Quería llegar a Moscú O sí más bien
fue un efecto de una retórica que se fue
amplificando durante el día retórica de
varios lados inclusive el presidente
también hubo algo de la falta de
obstáculos no que que que justamente no
encontró un rostop del Don que fue la
primera ciudad del sur a donde llega una
silla importante en términos logísticos
si esa falta obstáculos para seguir
avanzando no generaron esta trama que
hacía pensar en justamente una
sublevación no que podía llegar
eventualmente yo creo que hay una
pregunta importante no Qué es que estaba
pretendiendo prigo sí quería porque digo
es muy difícil pensar que prigo sin no
sabía que esto iba a generar un
enfrentamiento muy importante con con el
propio Putin Porque si bien él decía
Esto no es contra el presidente esto es
contra suministro de defensa Bueno
cuando vos tenés cinco mil hombres
armados que se están movilizando hacia
la capital Bueno es muy difícil no
pensarlo como una rebelión abierta al
presidente Así que la mente no él dijo
que que detenía esta marcha porque no
quería derramar sangre rusa digamos un
escenario que era bastante previsible a
la hora de empezar efectivamente una
marcha
Armada contra la cúpula militar rusa
Rodrigo precisamente recogiendo lo que
comentaba a Juan no dudas sobre qué
pretendía prehin y con qué apoyos
pensaba que contaba Aparentemente no
parece esto un poco una disputa dentro
de la cúpula militar rusa sobre Qué
hacer particularmente con Ucrania No
claro desde luego y como bien comentaba
Juan también es algo que venimos viendo
desde hace tiempo recordemos también es
vídeo del líder del grupo Wagner
acusando directamente a la cúpula
militar de dejarle sin municiones de
dejarle Sin comida con numerosos restos
de soldados Muertos del grupo Wagner a
sus espaldas a mí lo que me surge
también la duda es algo que también
comentaba Juan y es hasta dónde Quería
llegar prigo sin con este movimiento O
qué es lo que pretendía porque ya no
solo el hecho de que al principio no
hablara de ir de no ir contra Vladimir
Putin a mí me da la sensación de que
también quería ver qué es lo pensaba
Putin de la cúpula militar o quizás él
tenía alguna información de que Putin
también se ha podido cansar del devenir
de la guerra de cómo están llevando sus
generales esta guerra en Ucrania que
desde luego si bien parece que por el
momento están ahora consiguiendo frenar
Esa contraofensiva ucraniana no es lo
que estaban esperando desde un momento
desde un primer momento en Rusia claro
Rodrigo y Juan le traslado la pregunta
también porque se ha celebrado digamos
desde Ucrania y está esta crisis militar
dentro de Rusia desde occidente se ha
calificado como una falta de control por
parte de Vladimir Putin sin embargo
considera que está claro que esta
situación vaya a beneficiar a Ucrania
porque Wagner Parece que ya no va a
luchar en Ucrania porque no quiere
firmar el contrato que requería el
kremlin sin embargo el ejército ruso
puede incluso
lanzarse de forma más Feroz en la
ofensiva
y por eso yo sería cauto no en torno
entiendo también por qué Ucrania y por
qué voces occidentales que apoyan
Ucrania podrían justamente intentar
difundir esta narrativa de que de que
Putin está más débil no y de que
efectivamente podía haber un impacto
positivo para Ucrania en la guerra yo
sería cauto porque por lo que estamos
viendo hasta ahora en las últimas
semanas no ha habido un avance
significativo en términos de la
contraofensiva que en Ucrania por ahora
vemos a Rusia defendiendo bien digamos
sus líneas de defensa no parece haber un
cambio o no parecería haber un cambio
muy estructural en términos de la
dinámica de la guerra y ahí hay que
preguntarse efectivamente por el futuro
de vos decías bien esto de que estamos
viendo cierta renuencia quizás a
incorporarse estos mercenarios al
ejército ruso no sabemos Cuál va a ser
esa esa proporción porque una parte si
se va a incorporar quizás una parte no
vamos a ver realmente cómo cómo eso
termina impactando en el terreno pero
por lo pronto y al menos por las cosas
que Leo yo y por las cosas que consulto
no no estamos viendo un movimiento tan
significativo me parece para pensar en
que la guerra va a seguir un curso
distinto no de de todas maneras está por
verse no y el financial Times publicaba
hace hace un par de días que de hecho
oficiales de la otan consideran que la
contraofensiva ucraniana tampoco Está
avanzando en base a las expectativas que
se habían creado y que de eso también
dependería en un futuro a corto plazo
Pues en la ayuda
en términos económicos militares no que
se continuaba concediendo a Ucrania
Rodrigo Tenemos también poco tiempo para
abordar este tema ya tenemos que cerrar
pero una conclusión de Cara a la mirada
puesta quizás a la Cumbre de la otan O a
los al futuro más inmediato si yo
primero quería Añadir que además es
posible que ahora dentro del ejército de
Rusia quieran reforzar lealtad o sea
habrá muchos que estén lamentados con el
dedo sobre su lealtad o no a Putin
seguramente eso lo quieran demostrar
ahora en el campo de batalla de Cara a
Ucrania pues ya hemos escuchado al
propio celensky como bueno decir
comprendo que quizás una próxima entrada
en la otan sea después de la guerra sea
para más adelante ha cambiado el
discurso con respecto a lo que estaba
diciendo últimamente quería una entrada
ya quizás ya le han avisado de que no va
a ser posible y yo comprendo que los
países digan que si se alarga la guerra
hay mucho dinero invertido de por medio
también las sociedades de estos países
en algún momento dirán Lo siento pero no
podemos seguir apoyando Ucrania sí
veremos En qué en qué punto se pueden a
retomar estas conversaciones de
acercamiento estas negociaciones
eventualmente de paz y quien logra
mediarlas bien les trasladó ahora a otro
escenario para comentar una noticia de
último minuto Y es que el Tribunal
Superior electoral de Brasil inhabilita
finalmente al expresidente Jair
bolsonaro para los próximos ocho años
hasta 2030 rápidamente Juan Qué impacto
así un análisis en caliente Le pido para
la derecha en Brasil
bien A ver es una noticia de última hora
es muy relevante se venía viendo no Uno
veía siguiendo venía siguiendo la la
semana en Brasil y uno sentía que esto
podía pasar no recordemos esto surge a
partir de la reunión que tiene bolsonaro
tres meses antes de las elecciones con
Embajadores donde él reitera esta
crítica infundada digamos Sin evidencia
al sistema electoral de Brasil eso es lo
que empieza a jugar el Tribunal Superior
electoral a lo que él le suma también la
trama del golpe de estado o el intento
Mejor dicho del golpe de estado y el
discurso bolso ante el sistema electoral
eso es lo que se juzga por eso bolsonaro
es está inhabilitado yo tengo algunos
apuntes súper breves digamos lo primero
es diría Esto bolsonaro me parece a mí
tiene más miedo hoy de ir de ir a
prisión o sea de estar más que
inhabilitado estar de estar en la cárcel
O sea me parece que a él en su situación
judicial lo que más le preocupa ahora es
lo que se va a juzgar en torno a su
presidencia Yo creo que él está Más
enfocado en su situación judicial y en
Buscar me parece algún tipo de acuerdo
Yo creo que él ya estaba descontando que
él podía quedarse fuera de la elección
no yo creo que si eso le sirve para
evitar una condena en prisión yo creo
que sería favorable para su situación
personal al menos por lo que estamos
viendo en términos de su discurso y por
lo que sabemos en su entorno lo segundo
esto nos lleva directamente a compararlo
con la situación de Donald Trump en
Estados Unidos
extrema derecha que dejan El Poder y que
después en su contra pesan diferentes
investigaciones hay una gran diferencia
que que uno lo ve hoy a Trump en Estados
Unidos como alguien protagonista alguien
en el centro del escenario político
Porque seguramente sea candidato y tiene
todavía ganar entonces creo que lo que
vemos en Brasil es un bolsonero que está
más aislado que Trump en Estados Unidos
y último apunte y es la pregunta que un
poco les traslado digamos no es si con
bolsonaro fuera de la carrera es posible
pensar en un bolsonarismo conducido por
otro líder porque la base ahora es
posible que otro líder intente tomarla
Rodrigo te traslado exactamente esta
comparativa no tenemos dos ex
mandatarios que tienen muchísimas
investigaciones abiertas ya algunas que
otras en los juzgados pero sobre todo
las preliminares que apuntan a sus roles
en intentos de subvertir el orden
constitucional por decirlo suavemente
Cuáles serían a sus apuntes bueno es que
apuntaba al principio lea eso ese juego
de espejos entre Francia y Estados
Unidos la carrera de bolsonaro parece un
espejo de la de Donald Trump y veremos
se acaba de Donald Trump como él a mí lo
que me parece muy interesante en este
punto es que vemos como ante unas
instituciones fuertes del Estado los
actos tienen consecuencias veremos y
también lo tienen en Estados Unidos y es
interesante Porque tanto bolsonaro como
Donald Trump como otros líderes también
de distintos sectores políticos intentan
a veces coactar estas instituciones
poner a jueces que les sean más afines
precisamente para evitar este tipo de
juicios bueno Rodrigo Seguiremos sin
duda muy de cerca cómo avanza el
panorama político en Brasil también en
Estados Unidos y le propongo cerrar con
un tema que sé que Bueno usted Sigue muy
muy muy muy de cerca como gran
aficionado al ciclismo y es que la gran
cita del ciclismo internacional empieza
este fin de semana hablamos del Tour de
Francia Rodrigo escribía en un artículo
para France 24 el mes de julio en Europa
es difícil de entender sin la presencia
en televisión del Tour de Francia de los
ciclistas rodando por las carreteras
francesas un artículo que ustedes pueden
encontrar en la página web de France 24
en español firmado por Rodrigo sedano
Por qué están atractivo tan particular
este esta cita Bueno no sé si para todo
el mundo es atractivo desde luego para
mí como bien sabes si Rosa pero forma
parte del ideario colectivo yo creo de
no sé si de toda Europa pero de buena
parte de Europa que en verano se corre
el Tour de Francia Me parece muy bonito
que empiecen el país Vasco porque es una
de las regiones de todo el continente
europeo con mayor cultura de ciclismo
forma parte del día a día de mucha gente
allí creo que mañana vamos a ver unas
imágenes espectaculares en Bilbao mucha
gente en las carreteras y adelanto ya
que aunque haga mal tiempo van a estar
allí en las carreteras además el Tour de
Francia tiene este año un panel de
corredores pues probablemente de los
mejores que hemos visto este en los
últimos años rosa me parece interesante
también que vamos a empezar ya con
etapas muy bonitas donde va a haber
mucha disputa a veces el Tour de Francia
nos tiene acostumbrados a empezar con no
sé con unas tapas más Llanas un poco más
aburridas para entrar un poco digamos en
acción Yo creo que la gente si se acerca
a ver a sus televisiones o a la
carretera al Tour de Francia va a
disfrutar mucho Juan usted es aficionado
al ciclismo también va a seguir el Tour
de Francia
quizás ahora después lo que dice Rodrigo
pues nunca lo había ni considerado pero
ahora después lo que dice Rodrigo quizás
una una mirada le hecho Rodrigo muy
rápidamente unas particularidades y un
pronóstico para quien se va a llevar el
mayota amarillo este año muy rápido que
tenemos pocos segundos es difícil saber
quién se va a llevar Este Amarillo
porque la disputa va a ser grande Pero
principalmente podemos hablar de dos
nombres el danés Jonas binglegard
son los grandes vueltón a manos ahora
mismo agachar ha hecho una temporada
espectacular es casi ya una leyenda viva
de este deporte pero yo nací binglegard
le ganó el Tour el año pasado ha hecho
también unas carreras muy fuertes
Durante este inicio de temporada entre
ellos va a estar probablemente no serán
los primeros mayores amarillos mañana
quizás estemos hablando de nombres como
Mateo Van Der Paul o Goodbye para ese
primer mayor amarillo en en Bilbao
quizás alguno de los latinoamericanos
también presente en la lucha final
mañana creo que será más difícil pero es
bonito ver que ya está egan Bernal de
vuelta eso le iba a comentar este
esperado regreso bueno Rodrigo
Muchísimas gracias por habernos ayudado
a analizar el panorama Internacional de
la semana Le agradezco mucho su
participación en este programa gracias
por la invitación Rosa Juan Muchísimas
gracias por habernos acompañado también
en este espacio de Franz a 24 ha sido un
placer contar con su colaboración en
este espacio para mí también Rosa
Muchísimas gracias
y a ustedes Muchísimas gracias como
siempre por su atención le agradecemos
al equipo técnico a la producción por
hacer posible Este programa y recuerden
como siempre que pueden ampliar toda
esta y más información en France 24 y
24.com
[Música]